hey what's going on everybody its Sean
Evans host of first we feast
Cup our future should do some sort of
happy holidays I'm sure get it we get it
we get it we get it do I want to say
more things capisce I've eaten 500 room
temperature scorching hot chicken wings
wait how'd you open that up sorry I have
a pretty hard last night
[Music]
hey what's going on in happy holidays
hot ones fans it's Sean Evans sitting at
a table by himself and you know what
that means it's time for a fan Q&A what
we've done is we've drawn some of the
most pressing questions coming out of
season two season two it's over
it's okay we've watched that ship sail
we bring in season three into port
sometime in January taking a little
break to reload rearrange some things
but with season two coming to an end we
need to answer some of the most pressing
hot ones fans questions hot ones fans
they need to know and I need to talk
time to give the people what they want
let's start with question one what are
your plans for season three as far as
the plan for season three goes we're
gonna keep this show more or less the
same keep bringing you crazy people
gonna keep bringing you oddball is gonna
keep bringing you people who are under
the radar gonna keep bringing people to
the table we're gonna keep talking to
our favorite rappers we're gonna get
athletes chefs uh TV personalities
actors actresses we need to definitely
get more women in the studio that's a
big-time goal for season three but
otherwise we're more or less staying the
same just the same hot ones thing the
hot ones that you love does it piss you
off when you see hot ones rip offs on
YouTube and TV this is a great question
I've been told by brass not to get into
it too much but [ __ ] it I'm gonna say
some things I can't bite my tongue if
you want the real follow me on Twitter
I'm not recommending that you follow me
on Twitter I'm boring as hell on Twitter
I barely ever tweet unless it's to like
you know hey we got a new hot ones
episode or to embarrass a big media
company or some big YouTube channel
that's just blatantly ripping us off
also though it's an important
distinction because sometimes I think
that like
people see me like go off on Twitter and
they're like oh like what about fans and
stuff I love the fan videos the fan
videos are the best when I see hot ones
fans goofing off on YouTube and having
fun with the show it warms my heart my
cold dead black heart it makes it three
sizes bigger here is my like nice thing
all I'll say is this I'm very happy that
all the shows that rip us off [ __ ]
suck next from Kevin Hart to Action
Bronson there seem to be a lot of
controversy about the manners of your
dining companions what do you think of
the criticism this is a great question
I'm happy that it was in the Hat I don't
know what's in the Hat mappy this one
was in the Hat sometimes you know the
room is like electric and we have such a
great time together and it's a
conversation that starts before the show
and it's a conversation that continues
after the show and then we package it up
and we deliver it to the world and then
all of a sudden there's this wave of
people who in fairness I think just like
loved the show and sometimes they're
like defending me but I would just say
this
Kevin harp was an amazing shoot and then
same with Action Bronson like Action
Bronson and I were actually like kind of
talking about it on the side like what's
going on here but it's also too crazy
because I don't even know where the [ __ ]
encompasses like Bobby Lee's episode
comes out and there's seriously a
comment that's like here's a class act
like blah blah blah not like action or
not like Kevin Hart like the dude pooped
his pants at the dinner table like where
is the line what is the guiding
philosophy on what is and what is not
good table manners when you're on hot
ones I know that this sounds
self-serving but guests that come on our
show are just automatically cooler than
guests that go on other shows and I know
you're saying at home like oh Shama do
the math yourself if you're gonna do
press are you gonna go and do like five
different shows that are all on our
block or like whatever hit them all or
are you gonna blow out your afternoon
your night and the entire next day
eating wings on YouTube with me they're
the ones who come in here with no
guardrails they're the ones who say you
can ask me whatever
you want they're the ones who will eat
the wings that get hot crazy hot
so hot in fact that sometimes they spit
in garbage cans and snot on screen and
throw up I don't understand why their
humbleness comes into question it just
doesn't make any sense and I'm not out
to police YouTube comments however you
receive it however you think about the
show whatever role you think it's plain
that's cool by me - are you adding
hotter sauces to the lineup it's been a
while since someone bowed out who knows
maybe in season three we do go a little
bit hotter maybe we keep it the same we
haven't really discussed it and that's
because we're not really trying to kill
people with hot sauce that's not really
the point of the show we really think of
ourselves as an interview show so these
questions were excited to ask people and
we're excited to hear the responses and
the answers and honestly I don't think
this show is as good if they're just
dead on hot sauce by the third wing and
if that's disappointing to people listen
to this trust that those wings are hot
as [ __ ] as the show's developed now
people know people will sit down and go
I don't want to get dj khaled like I
want to because he the best they get the
Wall of shame they're like I'm not going
on the Wall of shame it's just it's just
different now now we don't have to
explain the show people know the show
and they sit down and they're just like
you some of them are fans of the show
and they talk about the show and they
get it they understand that if they bow
out there are serious consequences to
pay when did Sean know what he wanted to
do for a living and who were are his
biggest influencers that's a Brent Baker
question shout-out to Brett Baker
hotland superfan hot ones Power Rankings
I kind of always knew that I wanted to
do this and I was a little kid my dad
used to watch Letterman and he would
tape him so he'd like binge watch him on
a Saturday when I would sit down with
him and he'd be throwing his head back
laughing I'd make him pause and explain
the joke to me which I'm sure was highly
annoying for my dad but it was kind of
like at that moment that I was like oh
like lights camera action kind of just
struck a chord with me as far as my
biggest influences go Howard Stern and
David Letterman are one too and
interchangeable
the other two that are big are Jimmy
Kimmel and Adam Carolla anyway that's
that for the five people that were
interested how can you look yourself in
the mirror when you were serving guests
cold wings I hear this all the time from
the commenters I cannot fathom for the
life of me why people care so much this
is not Top Chef we're not trying to like
oh also if we really cared all the wings
tasted like maybe we wouldn't douse them
and pain 100% or douse them and blares
Megadeth sauce like the wings and the
taste and the presentation are very much
secondary to the hot sauce but we hear
you we will be investing in a warming
tray I think that it's an improvement
for the show going forward waving the
white flag we surrender I hit the nut
sir oh and because people are late which
gas struggled the most after the cameras
cut everybody knows the story about
Coolio everybody knows about Eddie Wong
I've talked about how riff raff had some
issues afterwards as currency did as
well but the number one after show and
this is new is Big Bite Martin garrix
who take small bites Martin I'm gonna
regret this Martin I'll remember you
said that it's I think he drank a little
bit too much milk and during the actual
episode he held it together like a pro
afterwards though he spent some time in
the complex bathroom and to his credit
though walked out like alright I still
want to go out tonight I'm still legal
to it so those questions are laid to
rest thank you very much for an
incredible year we've had I think it was
9 episodes in season one I think that we
did 41 in season 2 just week after week
pumping out those episodes I think it
was horrible from a health and my
digestive tract but damn it if we didn't
build something together and we hope to
give you more and we hope to give you
bigger and we hope to give you better in
2017 I hope to connect with you guys a
lot more in 2017 I know I'm I know I'm
distant I know I'm a little awkward I
know that I don't really uh I'm not like
a New York media like do
dude really where was that going with
that
[Music]